hello my name is steve kav min and i am
learning and link and today i will
talk about the fourth
secrets of
successful language learning the
first secret is
spending enough time 2 it is
forgetting
doing the
things you like the third is
developing the
ability make up for yourself the
ability to notice thats what happens in the
language  in the language that you try
to learn and
4 words are more important
than grammar why why because
if
there are many many reasons in the first I can’t
learn grammar
in grammar without
words I don’t understand I don’t understand all these
explanations I don’t understand if I don’t have
experience with the language i can't remember i to me
i can't use but even if
you have the ability
to understand and grammar without much experience
still without words and
without a
lot of words you can't say anything and
you don't understand
when you knock flies arte therefore  before
me, the most
fundamental thing is the
basis for learning these words and
when you have enough words
for  pass you can focus on
grammar but of course when I don't
start I will read a
little about grammar but I don't eat
it it's to possess yes it's it I
know that I'll
score it doesn't matter but now
because I've already heard a lot of me
there is
enough reason to stock up on Russian well,
now I can focus on
grammar and I am
getting a new right on
grammar and
I also say thank you very much to my
teacher about the
teacher on link evgeny who
made a great series about
Russian grammar pens which is called
practical grammar and there  there are many
explanations and many many examples it's
all in Russian and therefore I understand everything
I understood these words I understand these
explanations and we really want to please
this occasion it shines and the case many
times over and
so when I read not resources
in Russian  I can mark on a
understood this is the accusative case and this is so and
therefore when I study
any language my son increases it  words are
not stock and
grammar these will be 2
things that will be dealt with thanks